hey there and welcome to this pro flows
quick tip my name is cameron and today
we're going to talk about
a very simple technique or
trick i should say but it's very
powerful
and it's something that i run into all
the time and i thought
hey i'm gonna go ahead and teach this as
a quick tip
uh because it is so important to know
how to do this so
what i've got here is a camera i've got
a custom view
here i've got the straight on camera
here and in this custom
view you can see that i've got a logo
3d layer and i've got a background 3d
layer this is just a very simple example
but this could be anything like any type
of background plate
the logo text could be a logo it could
be another shape layer it could be
a photo anything it doesn't matter the
point is i want you to realize that
there's two
3d layers here and these layers if i hit
r for rotation
these layers are both rotated to the
same
angles of zero zero zero zero zero zero
now what happens if i for instance take
the y rotation of the logo
and i just kind of rotate it just
slightly and you can see
it intersects with this background plate
here
and when it does that it disappears into
the
the solid background and maybe for some
reason we don't want that to happen
maybe we still want to see
that full logo text or
logo icon here for whatever reason there
are many times
when working with 3d layers that layers
will intersect and you don't want them
to
intersect so i could do this
through this back out i do this on the
x-axis same deal here i'm just kind of
pivoting back here on the x and you can
see here
again it's just going through the layer
they're intersecting and i don't want it
to intersect so how do you
solve that easily how you do it is you
create a new adjustment layer
and the adjustment layer doesn't need to
have anything on it just a
blank adjustment layer and what you do
is you drag that adjustment layer
in between your two 3d layers so logo
and purple solid i drag it between and
boom
we can see here you can see the full
logo even though it's intersecting here
i'm still able to see the full logo here
so this doesn't work if the adjustment
layer is above
or if it's below it actually has to be
between the two 3d layers that you want
to
get rid of the intersection and what i
like to do is i like to rename these
cutters
that's just a personal preference and i
always lock these layers and that tells
me
this adjustment layer is here to stop
the intersection of these
two 3d layers and that's all it does i
don't need to add anything to it
i don't want to delete it or turn it off
i want it to be here and locked and that
is how you create a cutter
between two 3d layers in after effects